The second way for us to add to your social circle...
...is from your Google chat buddies.
If you have eight chat buddies,...
...we'll add those eight people to your social graph.
It's important to know that we don't publish your list of chat buddies,...
...we just add them to your social circle...
...so we can show you their public information.
The third way, we surface content from your social circle is through Google Reader.
For example, if you subscribe to a blog in Google Reader,...
...then we can surface a post from that blog in your social search results.
Once Google builds your social circle, things are pretty simple after that.
We take our regular Web index data and annotate it with social information.
When our algorithms determine that it would improve your search experience,...
...we surface public content from your social circle at the bottom of the search results.